ايه شفتوا شو هو يوسف وفي المقابل اعلنت
سلطاته شبه جزيره القرم المواليه لروسيا
استكمال اعمال الصيانه في سكه الحديد
المتضرره بين سيمبر بول وسيفاستوبل على ان
تستانف حركه النقل بشكل كامل يوم غدا ياتي
ذلك عقب تعليق عمل القطارات اثراء خروج
قطار شحن عن مساره وقد اشارت هيئه سكه
الحديد الى ان الحادثه وقع بسبب اعمال
تخريبيه قام بها مجنون بينما حمل الرئيس
برلمان شبه جزيره القرم اوكرانيا مسؤوليه
الحادث وكان جهاز امن الدوله الروسيه اكد
فتح تحقيق في اسباب الحادث على ان يتم
الاعلان عن نتائجه بعد اتمام عمليات
التحقيق
ومعنى الان من جنازه العقيد الكسندر
الفوترافير رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه اهلا وسهلا بك اريد ان ابدا من
الخبر الذي بدانا في هذا الملف ان الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه
اعلنت ان زيلنسكي اصدر مرسوما رئاسيا
بتشكيل مجلس لتحرير القرن ماذا يعني هذا
طبعا كما هو معلوم ان كل الطرفين
المتحاربان سيلجان الى التفاوض في نقطه
معينه لكن في البدايه يجب ان نتفق على
نقاط التفاوض بهذا السبب كل خطوه في هذا
الاتجاه سيكون مرحب بها لكن حاليا نحن
بعيدون جدا عن اي تفاوض ممكن ولكن عندما
يعني
يقرر الرئيسكي ان يشكل لجنه معنيه بتشكيل
مجلس لتحرير القرن هذا المعطى ما الذي
يعنيه في هذه المرحله وكيف يؤثر على
التفاوض هنا
من الناحيه التاريخيه نحن نعلم انه سيكون
من الصعوبه بمكان استعاده
شبه جزيره القرن بالطبع هناك حاله شذو جذب
واي موقف تفاوضى يجعل كل طرف يطالب بالحظ
الاقصى ومن ثم يكون هناك تفاوض البحث عن
سبل اخرى لتحقيق المقاصد نحن ما زلنا
بعيدون من رؤيه اوكرانيا وهي تستعيد القرن
هل هي بالنسبه لاوكرانيا مرحله للرد على
هذا الهجوم الجوي المكثف الذي استهدف كيف
في الاسبوع الاخير من هذه الحرب في ظل
ايضا احباط الجانب الروسي من عدم حسم
الامور في باخمت واستمرارها لفتره طويله
اعتقد ان هناك قضيتان مختلفتان تماما
السبب الذي يجعلنا نرى هذا الهجوم الواسع
النطاق باستخدام صواريخ جوالك كروز بانواع
مختلفه من جانب روسيا لاننا نمر بمرحله
استنزاف الروس
يعتقدون ان الاوكرانيين يعانون من نقص في
الصواريخ في الدفاع الجوي وهم يستخدمون كل
ما بحوزتهم بما في ذلك
الصواريخ صواريخ ارض الجو لكي يستنزفوا
قدرات اوكرانيا قدر المستطاع الروس
يستخدمون كل ما في حوزتهم من سلاح وخاصه
الفرط صوتيه منها
يجعل الاوكرانيين نستنفذوا كل ما لديهم من
صوا ريخ
هل هذا هو السبب الوحيد ام ايضا يعني هذا
سيؤثر على موقف اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق
بتزويدها بطائرات اف 16
هل يزيد من فرص حصولها على المزيد من
الدعم العسكري هنا
اعتقد ان هذه القضايا غير مرتبطه بما
نتحدث عنه بالتاكيد في مرحله ما اوكرانيا
ستحتاج الى استبدال طائراتها المقاتله لكن
ما يحدث حاليا ان روسيا تطلق كل ما لديها
من صواريخ طبعا كل هذا يكلف
كلفه هذا لان كلفه صاروخ كنجال يضاهي كلفه
طائره التفوق جوي روسيا اذا في كل مره
تطلق فيها روسيا صاروخا من هذا النوع يشبه
الامر كانها تخسر واحده من افضل مقاتلاتها
ومن يستخدمون الكثير من هذه الصواريخ
وينفقون الكثير من الاموال لانهم يعتقدون
ان اوكرانيا قريبا
ستفقد كل ما لديها من صواريخ دفاعيه جويه
من جنوب العقيده
رئيس تحرير المجال العسكري السويسريه شكرا
جزيلا